hey guys welcome back to brain you were
back on Monster Hunter world again and
today we're gonna be going over how to
defeat the new monster extremely Hemanth
which is of course just the normal
behemoth but just way worse and as well
going over the new changes that have
been changed from the original version
to the extreme version which hopefully
will be still getting updated but we'll
get into that a little bit later in the
video but as always let's get started
so yeah first up are the changes and
first is that the tornado move is
basically gonna be popping out almost
instantly so try to have a sword and
shield user always ready to flash him
sleeping and dropping at Crystal and the
first phase will do 5100 damage making
his total HP run 50k the old health was
around 35 K and a cool to Roth's health
is 41 K so this is 9,000 health more
than coal to Roth which is an absolute
crazy amount the meteors now applied
defense down the ecliptic meteor is now
in Phase one he only drops two comets in
the first phase and one common in the
Phase two so definitely keep an eye on
all those come so that you don't lose
them and due to his tempered status he
can also only not only be flashed two
times thought the fight on top of that
three ecliptic meteors are dropped in
the phase four and now this number could
be higher in law I'm not entirely sure
if this is accurate but there's
definitely more than one meteor in the
fourth phase obviously at the end the
last face he would reign down the
ecliptic meteor and then kill himself
this is not the case after the first one
is done you still got two more to go
before the fight is over
on top of that Phase three there is not
going to be an ecliptic meteor depending
on the situation it's actually a DPS
check if you do enough damage he will
move on to the fourth area without an
ecliptic meteor but if you don't do
enough he will cast the ecliptic meteor
and then you're screwed because there is
no comets in this face and on top of
that the last two things is that the
time limit is now 30 minutes instead of
35 and you can also dodge the ecliptic
meteor now by walking out of the area so
hopefully you're near the exits when
that happens going off the physiology
report is head and tail are the weak
points with those exact places and his
front legs being breakable or severable
for max damage everyone except sword
users should hit him in the head
soldiers should go between the tail and
head as they choose to still get max
damage out of all four of his legs I
like to go for the front only because
they are more breakable so that's just
my preference and his weakest element is
dragon with all elements being the same
at two stars for
recommendations I recommend Rocksteady
mental and temperament or good picks but
you can swap either one of them for a
health boost if you'd like to support
the team mega max and Asian potions work
really well
demon drugs and armor skins are also
really wonderful and no berries for the
Thunderbolt move which we'll get into
later and iron skin which will help
against the defense down which like I
said we'll also talk a little bit more
in depth when we get to that move I've
also seen a lot of people online when
they fight behemoths whether that be
solo with the regular behemoth or now
with this extreme behemoth although
there isn't too many videos with the
extreme behemoth one but I've seen a lot
of people either run a four-man squad or
a one-man squad with the heavy bow gun
using these stickies the clusters or the
slicing MO so that definitely might help
I personally not arranged users so I
wouldn't know how good these are but I
do believe these are one of the some of
the best mo types for the ranged weapons
so I would definitely recommend those if
you're gonna be rocking the heavy bouken
as well getting onto the moves we have
the first one is the shoulder charge it
is a very quick move you need to be
paying attention to this at all times
for this fight basically he's going to
be turning to you and if you're at a
relatively far distance and he looks at
you like the one on screen that all you
want to do is immediately Superman jump
if you're barely moving or walking or if
you're running sideways keep running
sideways and hopefully won't get hit by
this because this can do some serious
damage especially for how quick this
move is this is actually on screen right
now is how much damage I took and all I
had was a simple rock steady mantle and
it did about 60% of my health in one hit
the tornado attack is next up and yes
like I said he could still be flashed
during this move although the window is
a lot shorter so if you're playing solo
get really lucky with it or hope a
teammate is on standby with the weapon
and he also casts the move almost
instantly you have enough time to flash
about him but if you don't run around
the edges of the area you are in because
of the increased damage he will cart
your squad a whole lot faster with this
remember from the beginning he can only
be flashed twice because he is
considered a tempered monster now and if
you can't run to the edges of the arena
or wherever you happen to be fighting
because of the fast cast time then run
to an area away from the other tornados
or areas you wouldn't mind losing access
to so preferably if you're in the
Crystal Room trying to have the tornados
underneath the crystals or anything like
that just so you can get that extra
damage and not get hit by them next is
this simple explosion moved while this
also is very damaging it's also a pretty
simple move to dodge you have a look at
whoever he's going to cast this on
hunched down and then turn red once this
happens and if anywhere near his front
legs you can run away
or if you're directly in front of him
you want to be Superman jumping with
this instance with defense down I
believe this is a one-shot move so be on
the lookout for this because this is
going to do crazy amounts of damage if
you're caught in this move up next is
the standard meteor we'll get to the
ecliptic meteor in a second but for the
standard one this too personally to me
feels like it has a bigger blast radius
but I also could be wrong on that either
way he launches about two or three even
four meters at one time in the first
stage because obviously in the old
behemoth why he would maybe do one
meteor on the person he has a grow to
now he's just launching meteors to
everybody so be prepared at all times
for that and like I said stated before
this move if you're hit it applies the
defense down debuff which makes you take
more damage to attacks as you can see
about my teammates healthbar he was hit
by the move and then given defense down
as well as a flame type of blight so
obviously what the flame boy all you
have to do is just dodge for all three
times and that will get rid of the flame
the only real counter to this move is to
obviously not get hit by either dodge
rolling or Superman jumping or have the
skill iron skin which is a level one at
30% defense resistance at level two is a
60% defense resistance and level 3 or
maxed out is full resistance to defense
down so I honestly think this is an
absolute necessary thing for this fight
next move is is ecliptic meteor this
moves still one shots like normal but I
will go over the changes real quick just
to say it again he uses the ecliptic
meteor in phase 1 or stage 1 or area 1
or whatever you want to call it that
used to not be the case before but now
it is in phase 1 he will have two comets
in phase 2 2 he will only drop one so be
careful on these areas because there's
only two ways to survive this and that's
either by hiding behind the comments
that he drops and if there isn't any
left then you want to be using the new
emote jump the Final Fantasy 15 jump emo
this will actually dodge the move if you
do within certain timing and since
there's not really many comets he seems
to be dropping according to these notes
then you definitely want to keep this
handy on the radial menu so you can use
this whenever you can as quick as
possible and then lastly is thunderbolt
and sadly I didn't record this part but
according to what like I said the
changes for this thunderbolt is not used
in rapid succession and multiple casts
are in a row after the first initial
phases are going to be a lot more
casting but at the beginning I stated
like I said these come out more rapidly
so if you're caught then Superman dive
but if you're in between the lines stay
put because you're going to be needing
that split second of time before he
does it again to run to the next open
spot immediately so you don't get
damaged and if you're shocked by this
and somehow miraculously are not dead
then from this move you're going to be
receiving a thunder blight eating a null
berry will solve this problem really
quickly but I recommend only doing that
after that after the thunderbolt move is
done because if you try to do it in
between it will definitely catch you and
you'll be shocked and then you're going
to die and that guy's is going to be the
end of the guide for extreme behemoths
this boss is an absolute [ __ ] I really
hate this but it's probably the hardest
boss that monster on our world has at
this current moment even though it's
just a harder version of a current one
behemoth was already tough enough now we
have the extreme version it's just
making things way harder than it needs
to be see how hopefully guys learned a
lot about this fight especially with the
new changes I'm so glad that this came
out on reddit
I'm really happy thank you Sten PI of
course for the credit to him I'll leave
the link in the description down below
if you want to check it like I said it
might be getting updated more a lot more
times by the time this video is uploaded
but yeah I like to view if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I'll cover the
solo guides of the monsters in Monster
Hunter world and on top of that my two
monsters in videos will be on screen if
you guys don't wanna check that out
right a guy's hope ever yesterday they
give art to the video and pieced out
[Music]